foreign
[Music]
kill Tony's 10-year anniversary show
took place last night and the amount of
wild unexpected [__] that happened was
insane ten [__] years
from people fighting for their jobs
unannounced drop-ins and some of the
craziest bucket pulls we've ever seen it
only seemed right to make this video
recapping the entire thing to help us
cover everything that happened last
night we had the pleasure of working
with the great people over at kill alley
kiltony's extremely unofficial
docu-series podcast they have a dope
YouTube channel making many
documentaries every week about the
comedians who sign up for kill Tony and
last night we're outside the show
Gathering behind the scenes footage and
interviews for this video hey what's
going on joke world I'm Sonny Carlin I'm
over here at ACL live for the 10-year
anniversary of kill Tony so through the
day it's been 10 years my name is DK
we're here at kill Tony 10. my name is
Audrey Scott a comedian we got these
wristbands not sure where they're going
to put us but hopefully it has a
bathroom and a nice and
just [__] showed up I didn't know
anything I have my sister like in the
car running and so it's the 10th
anniversary of kiltoni and hopefully
like the [__] pick for one have you
signed up before yeah for like like
almost two years
and everybody that I meet gets picked
except for [__] Me Make some noise
for Juanita
we're all gonna be here together
oh [__] here we go let's [__] go
why'd you sign up uh I think uh Tony
this show right here this podcast does a
lot for the comics especially the
working Comics uh fortunately a lot of
people sign up that not ready for comedy
uh but also that's kind of what makes
the show but the good Comics they
actually uh you know they get a little
recognition and they show their hard
work it's a great opportunity I think
kill Tony has made more people famous
than American Idol which I think is a
huge accomplishment you know
please let me know what William
Montgomery singles I'm in a redhead
if you could pull tonight are you ready
oh shoot I'm always [__] ready dude
my life man like I'm ready I'm ready I
would love to be pulled I'm really here
to uh I hope Jared Nathan kills it shout
out to Jared love you so much kill it
dude if you get pulled tonight are you
ready yeah I'm ready yeah I'm not
nervous at all oh yeah of course I'm
ready I'm always ready anytime they're
ready to pull me which is kind of what
I'm waiting for every time I'm back here
I'm gonna go with what I got and if it
doesn't work it's only gonna be a minute
of hell you can't even die in a minute
yeah you can kill in a minute but you
can't die put your hands together for
Kent Hunter everyone Kent Hunter
foreign
[Applause]
a little nervous is that why your entire
lower half is shaking right now
that is incredible do we have a camera
zoomed in on that for the love of God
holy [__] that is unbelievable I didn't
talk much in the interview they were
just joking on me the whole time
yeah maybe the leg they were joking
about my legs so that's good what do you
think about joke world and kill Ally
collaborating I'm pretty stoked it means
more people are gonna say I have Down
syndrome than before so I'm excited
about that I've been watching all your
[__] comments too now that I know
never gonna stop looking as far as the
actual show the live stream started off
with an opening tribute to Bob Saget
Gilbert Gottfried Brody Stevens and
Michael Lair then the band played for
about 30 minutes which I'm sure was cool
in person but with all the anticipation
building up on the live stream it felt
like they were on forever also everyone
had on these really cool jackets I gotta
mention that part kill Tony definitely
did not disappoint with all the special
guests that they had for this event for
the two panel seats they went about as
big as possible with Austin's own Joe
Rogan and Tom Segura
go
I'm Segura
it was hype seeing both of these guys as
the guests for this episode obviously
huge names with an already established
back and forth but to be honest as the
show went on I started to realize that
they were both kind of quiet
I can't really think of many things Joe
or Tom actually said but it was still
cool that they were there the show is
joined by even more unannounced special
guests that dropped in at random times
to make brief small appearances
including theovan Ron White and Brian
Holtzman Theo was there for maybe a
total of 25 seconds literally just said
what's up and then dipped Ron White came
up on stage for a few minutes as well
but Brian Holtzman was the only one to
actually do stand-up have you ever seen
a woman in a wheelchair blower rape
whizzle the live stream also included
some major developments involving the
current cast of Kill Tony regulars Hans
Kim David Lucas and William Montgomery
things started off with Hans Kim opening
up the show like usual but right after
his set ended Tony announced that for
the first time ever there was going to
be a battle for regular ship and Hans
was being challenged for his weekly spot
on kill Tony by a golden ticket winner
named Enrique Chacon I'm going to let
you decide who moves on to be the new
keltoni regular just like the rules of
the Mexican drum offs on kill Tony the
winner was chosen by Applause which this
time strongly favored Hans Hans Kim is
the [__] ladies and gentlemen
hasta luego
Hans will get to decide when Hans
retires from the show something tells me
that either kill Tony is ready to
replace Hans Kim or Hans is wanting to
move on because shortly after Hans won
this matchup Tony announced that there
would be another Challenger for him to
face on Monday's episode it looks like
there's gonna be a few new kill Tony
regulars for us to get used to on top of
Hans potentially being on his way out
David Lucas announced his kill Tony
retirement last night on the live stream
after his normal roast battle with Tony
this is officially his full-time
retirement party right now in front of
you guys
many people in the audience were very
surprised by this announcement obviously
but as Tony said during the show these
guys have taken off the past few years
and now have more time that they need to
focus on their own careers plus they'll
still have the option to pop in on
Mondays and perform on all the episodes
of kill Tony they want instead of having
to be there every single week like I
mentioned before there was big news from
all three of the regulars last night as
William Montgomery officially became the
second member of the esteemed kill Tony
Hall of Fame William's parents were
there for the induction ceremony which
closed out the entire event it has been
a real pleasure being a part of kill
Tony for the past nearly five years and
I just want to say this could have been
the best podcast of all time except for
red bands [__] ass
because of everything that happened with
Hans Kim and David Lucas moments before
there was one part at the end where Tony
asked William Montgomery about his
future on the show in which the Hall of
Famer guaranteed that he's here to stay
and a huge shout out to cam Patterson
who was officially named as a new
regular on the show cam has been
electric on screen so far and I can't
wait to see more the show ended with a
special announcement that already makes
the thumbnail of our last video false
kill Tony is going to be doing an arena
in Austin Texas this New Year's Eve this
podcast in an arena on New Year's Eve
congratulations thank you so much a Live
Comedy podcast in an arena this is
absurd this show has continued to just
keep leveling up at an insane rate
congrats to kill Tony for 10 amazing
years and congrats to you for watching
this entire video please subscribe
at joke world
and the world is wrld
[Music]